représentant canadien
aux cérémonies d'ouverture et
de fermeture des Jeux à Pékin.
d'un boycottage comme celui-là,
surtout dedededede de COVID?
Yann Roche est professeur
au département de géographie de
du sport
Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'?
Est-ce que ça peut vraiment
faire bouger la Chine sur les
droits de la pe e e e e e pense
que ça a déjà été dit d
personne ne s'attend à ce que ça
bouge de façon vraiment
importante. L'important était de
marquer le coup et de ne pas
laisser les choses se dérouler
comm a a a a a avait envie de le
faire, c'est-à-dire sans aucune
anicroche sans aucune réaction
de la communauté internation
Par contre, tout le monde a bien
mentionné et je pense qu'il yc'é
Angeles en 80 et en 84, certains
était d'accord mais il f
- C'est un message qu'on envoie
à la Chine si je comprends bien
mais est-ce que ça peut faire
a a a a a a a Chine quand même?e
que ces jeux sont importants
- Tout à fait, c'est très
important pour la Ch
déjà commencé à utiliser un peu
sa machine à images pour
promouvoir ces jeux, indiqué que
ça allait être de très grands
allait montrer à quel point la
Chine étais.s.s.s.s.s.s.s. Il
compte beaucoup là-dessus pour
continuer une stratégie de
l'image et le fait d'a
boycott diplomatique va surtout
leur faire perdre tout petit pee
que c'est surtout en termes
p p p p p p p peut jouer. Ça ne
changera pututututututututututuy
avoir des mesures de
représailles.
- Ça ne changera pas la
politique vis-à-vis des Ouïgour.
- Je pense que non, très
sincèrement. J'espère me trompes
longtemps, ils analysent lasitue
de propagande menée par les
États-Unis et leurs alliés, quei
se sont rendus là-bas se sont
rendus compte, qui sont neutres,
se sont rendus c
formation professionnelle. Donc
à ce niveau, pour eux, ils n'ont
rien fait de mal, tout se passes
et leurs alliés et le Canadat tn
allié très dossier des États-
Unis.
- Et est-ce que le Canada doit
craindre des représailles? P
aurait des conséquences.
- Il y a de fortes chances que
le Canada est à craindre des
représailles surtout que la
manière don
États-Unis se sont exprimés dans
un premier temps, ensuit
eu l'Australie et le Royaume-
Uni, et le Canada avait parlé
avait dit d'attendre quelques
jours avant de se décider et les
décès qu'au lieu d'apparaître
dans un Front commun, Canada à
l'air de suivre les
longtemps qu'on s'est exprimé au
Canada notamment en février
Chambre des communes parnananane
qui se passait. Mais la manière
s s s s s s s s s s sont passé,
Canada apparaît comme un pays
qui suit les États-Unis et
rappelez-v
Michael et de Meng Wang joue, on
était un peu dans le collimateus
mesures de répression sans dout.
- Et est-ce que le Canada
d'après vous aurait dû agir plus
vite parce que certains de
longtemps de cela depuis
longtemps qu'on
- Je ne sais pas comment cela
s'est passé dans les couliss
en quelque sorte. De toute
depuis très longtemps. Je pense
que le Canada ne pouvait même
pas y
y aller de manière tout à fait
neutre comme
passé. Par contre, il aurait
sans doute fallu, et je suppose
que peut-être certainest t t tÉs
peut-être en géraient les choses
èèèèèèèèèèèès
consensuelle. Mais rappelez-vous
qu'en 2008 à Beijing, Stephen
Harper ne s'était
Donc des boycott diplomatique ou
du moins partiel, ça a déjà étéa
avait même mené à un
rafraîchissement des relations
entre le Canada et la Chine à ce
moment-là
- Est en ce moment, les
relations sont très tendue